while a mother is breaking her silence
regarding a child abuse investigation at
a local elementary school a special ed
teacher is accused of hitting multiple
students as a form of discipline eight
news now education reporter Joshua
peguero takes a closer look at this
lawsuit
the prince of wagerheim Elementary was
reassigned earlier this year amid two
child abuse investigations there haven't
been formal charges yet but Sabrina Bell
says she's thankful for the
Whistleblower who exposed the alleged
abuse for those who did witness who did
report it
Bailey and I are thankful more than you
would ever know because it's easy to
just turn a blind eye
and let things go in a lawsuit filed in
federal court Captain Fitzgerald is
accused of grabbing Belle's daughter
Bailey Ray by the wrist or hand then
pinching and squeezing her in between
the child's index finger and thumb she
was using physical punishment to
restrain my child it was documented
actually
by CCSD that after one of these
incidents where she was
pinched she was crying I mean she was
physically in pain Bailey is five years
old in his non-verbal autistic last year
Clark County School police investigated
Fitzgerald she was not charged but
police found there was an attempted
cover-up among administrators and staff
of the alleged abuse gerheim's principal
Ryan Lewis was moved to another school
Bell's attorney Greg Hubley says this
points to systemic issues at CCSD no one
was held responsible no one was held
accountable for what happened to Bailey
Ray and for what happened to the other
uh dozen or so children who were in this
classroom CCSD confirmed to me that
Fitzgerald is currently working at
gerheim a CPS report revealed that she
quote does Pinch the students as a form
of discipline and adds that quote
Fitzgerald has a pattern of behaviors of
intentionally inflicting pain on her
students to correct their behavior Clark
County schools has a policy of not
commenting on pending litigation I spoke
to Catherine Fitzgerald and she says in
part I have never abused a student or a
child the associate superintendent send
forms to parents alleging I abuse or
neglected students the Clark County
School District associate superintendent
should be held accountable back to you
guys